do do you have a quota for every day or
every night that you're supposed to meet
yeah you're supposed to make yeah a
certain amount
1,500 yeah and when you make that you
can go home yeah or the the last that I
can make is a b and how uh how many days
a week will you
work um every day really every day yeah
every day your money
machine and the tricks what kind of
requests do they
make like crazy requestes are man you
got some you got some people out there
that's very nasty you know that don't
even give a [__] and [__] ask
sucking on and like you know just there
and [__] I don't do that that's
disgusting as [__] but yeah you have a
lot of requests out
there you got to protect yourself huh
you got to protect yourself for sure and
that's when you walk away from the car
they're going to find somebody out there
to do it
s